hi
everyone i'm thomas benkowski from the
system redux dev team
today we'll be showing you the
possibilities that the new generation of
consoles have provided us with
and the effects that they have on the
system redux
we've been able to create more immersive
worlds with the new generation of
consoles
thanks to this we effectively combine an
atmosphere of psychological horror
and dark cyberpunk future
skillful use of lightning made possible
by next-gen technology
in combination with newly available 4k
textures
special effects like smoke fork and rain
have allowed us to create a world that
is even more dystopian
and truly cyberpunk
we don't only use light to create an
environment that is staged for our
horror experience
but we also use it to tell our story
better by highlighting important things
in the game
and by leading the player to the places
that he might not normally have noticed
as a result we've created a new level of
fear and anxiety
two essential paths in our psychological
horror experience
we are extremely excited about the
possibilities that the new consoles
provide
thanks to that observer's oppressive
world gets a second life
the new lightning system is only as good
as the materials and objects it
illuminates
[Music]
character models have been created from
scratch with all new textures
refinement of skin fur cybernetic
implants
eyes and animations we've been able to
rise the level of immersion
creating an even more realistic world
for what server
observer was revealed and augmented for
the next generation of consoles
the level of detail and the new enhanced
graphics are just two parts of the core
elements that we're introducing in the
system redux
we can't wait to tell you more about the
rest in the near future